we go to Mexico City and here's Manuel
rap hello to take us through well I
alluded to it before but it was a news
conference which the White House
announced changes to the border
situation with Mexico
that's right Kemal and we've been
expecting this announcement for some
time now even last week we heard from
Mexican officials who said that a
partial closure of the United States
Mexico border would not be off the table
for containment of co19
given that even now there are still so
many more cases in the United States
compared to here in Mexico and an
important thing to know perhaps
especially for our viewers who live
along the u.s. southern border is that
this partial closure announced by the
United States only a little more than
one hour ago
will affect tourism and only land border
crossings and it will not affect trade
it will not affect people's ability to
to go to work if they work across the
border but there but but there were a
few other points where President Trump
and may have sent mixed messages as well
which especially in regards to Mexico
shutting down flights from Europe we're
still waiting to hear confirmation for
the Mexican from Mexican authorities
whether or not that's going to be true
though there are a lot of people here in
Mexico who would see this as a positive
positive measure given that Mexico has
been reluctant to take some of the more
serious or even extreme measures that
many of them neighboring countries have
taken such as canceling flights or
shutting down schools come on who else
gets affected by this one Manuel from
Mexico I'm wondering about because again
Donald Trump he said a lot on that news
conference but there was talk about
illegal immigration legal immigration
the differences between the two and who
gets affected certainly well there's
again mixed messages and a lot being
said but basically the argument that
we're hearing from the United States is
that health officials in the United
States are concerned over the potential
for a quote mass uncontrolled border
movement but again we're hearing mixed
messages earlier in the day we heard
from Mexican Foreign Minister Marcelo
Ebert who had said that Mexico will not
be accepting any asylum seekers or
migrants or refugees from
third party countries in that press
conference that we heard from president
Trump and Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
secretary Pompeo said that that element
of this agreement between the United
States and Mexico had yet to be
finalized that an announcement would be
made
president Trump chimed in saying that no
third party nation asylum seekers would
be entering Mexico so at the moment we
simply don't know exactly what that
policy is but to answer your question
about who's going to be most effective
and most effective in this case we have
to have our minds on on migrants on
asylum seekers or thousands of
individuals from all over the continent
from Latin America in the case of
Venezuela some four point nine million
people have fled the country in the
context of their economic crisis in
Central America countries like Honduras
El Salvador Guatemala there are
thousands of migrants and asylum seekers
that are in Mexico that are but probably
more than probably the most vulnerable
people in the population so again these
are policies these are agreements that
are being made between the United States
and Mexico but we have yet to see how
that's going to be implemented given
that when it comes to deportations that
the United States wants to impose there
are several countries that have halted
deportation flights so again a lot of
policies that are up in the air a lot of
MIS mixed messages but that's what we're
hearing from officials both in the
United States and Mexico come on Manuel
Rapala rounding out our trip around the
world with our correspondents thank you
so much for that